There are other human
beings on Mars now.
Coexistence may prove
just as challenging
as it does on Earth.
ELON MUSK: Mars
civilization ultimately
looks like an advanced
version of Earth.
SUSAN WISE BAUER: Industry
is going to be absolutely
vital to that effort.
Lokrum is a
private corporation.
And Linus, you're
here to make a profit.
ANDY WEIR: If there's
money to be made,
then people would go
there to make the money.
ANTONIA JUHASZ: The Arctic
is a perfect example of this.
We see companies looking at the
Arctic as a porthole for oil.
Space is the new frontier.
It's unexploited.
What's that saying?
Drill, baby, drill?
Your crew has cut into
a scientific preserve.
What you're doing is not right.
CASEY DREIER: Any time
science reaches a conclusion,
you are going to face pushback.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: The
history of human conduct,
we have plenty of evidence
of things going wrong.
Who's side are you on?
There are no real
boundaries here.
Mars is going to
be more dangerous.
There's a contagion going
through Lokrum colony.
What the hell's
going on in there?
ADAM FRANK: Consequences are
going to be dire for everybody.
I don't know what to do.
STEPHEN PETRANEK: The
cost of being foolish
is so high that you will fail.
There's one thing
Mars teaches you.
It's patience.
BILL NYE: Space exploration
brings out the best in us.
It's where we
solve problems that
have never been solved before.
No one can control
what happens on Mars.
The planet has a way of making
sure actions have consequences.